families are offering words of
encouragement to a durango high school
student tonight josh ocampo was elected
homecoming queen but reportedly got in
trouble for wearing a pride flag kate
houston is live in the newsroom with the
changes that parents would like to see
kate
yes homecoming is supposed to be a night
of celebration for many high school
students for josh ocampo it quickly
turned sour a mom i spoke to says many
students were visibly upset and want
changes to be made
durango high school senior joshua campo
was elected homecoming queen to a
roaring applause in this video you can
see them pulling out a pride flag after
giving an impromptu speech ocampo says
they were told it was a campus
disturbance a mother of two durango high
school students says this is
unacceptable and may make other students
fearful to be themselves you could have
done something huge for this
for this school for these kids the ones
that are still scared to come out
the ones are fearful you just set that
back the ccsd code of conduct and dress
code regulation does not mention flags
lopez wants the school administration to
apologize to ocampo and their family
ocampo says they're at home until school
administration speaks to their parents
i did reach out to the school district
for more information on this and i'm
waiting to hear back from them we have
also connected with ocampo and you will
hear from them tonight at 11 so stay
with us back to you denise